[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad here we go this is it this
is the moment everyone's been waiting
for i know everyone's super excited for
this and so am i because we are in the
presence of a legend he started off as a
nrl gun playing for teams including the
warriors panthers and manly as well as
representing his country at the highest
level with the kiwis but all those
sporting successes are easy to forget is
post footy he's been able to create not
just a cool brand but a culture in the
form of yktr he sells some of the
coolest clothes on the planet and has
one of the best podcasts in the game
he's also created yktr sports which is
changing sports media and along the way
he's been inspiring so many by being
always willing to share his knowledge
and of course like all my guests are he
is an absolute lad he's one of the
greats it is isaac john welcome bro
thanks for having me back again
are we going to talk about this
yeah well may i forgot to push record
starstruck is one of the greatest
content creators on the podcast i've got
about 10 minutes through but we're back
and we're live and we're ready to go not
live but we're ready to go
once again thank you for the kind intro
um it's always it's always weird when
you hear those types of things obviously
you move so quickly through your day and
when people start to reflect like that
it's really interesting to hear and um
yeah grateful grateful to be here bro
how do you look back on your career
because obviously you've done so much
your footy was probably what four five
years ago now how do you look back on
your sort of footy career i don't really
remember it to be honest like i never i
remember when i played football like
whenever we used to go out in and like
talk to girls i never used to tell
people i was a football player like i
hated being associated just as a
football player never used to post like
football i most i post more stuff about
me playing now than i did back then i
kind of had this weird sticker stigma
within me that i didn't really want to
tell people but i really enjoyed it like
many of the lessons that i learned in
business transfer over um plenty of them
don't as well so
i look back with fond memories i had
some great coaches in terms of ivan
clary and mentors and um it's it's a
skill set that you learn that you can
transfer to your next part of your life
if you use it correctly like the the
biggest one is like feedback loop like
in a game you can make a mistake and on
the run you have to fix it and then get
over it and then sort of move on to the
next play or if the shape isn't working
you have to make adjustments and then
why that's all happening bro you've got
everyone sort of watching you as well
and then you're on national television
yeah so i think the feedback loops
really interesting when i look back on
it now and then you have to go to monday
we'll sit in front of a video and your
names come up and isaac john mistak will
let you try
so
that style um i really appreciate that
now because that's what business is like
like oh this isn't working cool let me
make an adjustment on the go
and i sort of see myself as like a half
back as well like when when the game's
on the line i'm with the ball and when
we lose i'm happy to front the camera
and say [ __ ] we [ __ ] up so um plenty
of lessons there bro one thing i did
want to start with was a childhood
friend of yours i know you grew up with
them in
tokyo how good was it to see quade
cooper back out there the other weekend
kicking the winning goal for the
wallabies yeah full circle and obviously
not just kicking the goal against anyone
was against the box as well so they're
defending champs the thing i loved about
it is sort of the kick was great and
even just the way he sort of summed
himself up afterwards and um talked
about his ego obviously he got hodge
there who's got he's a station wagon
like he's got a big boot you know what i
mean so he could knock it over pretty
easily
but backed himself and got it done and
just even seeing his reaction it was
more like
give us give us something quaid not just
the old humble like
you're grateful
uh but yeah really enjoyed a speech
afterwards and sort of harry carrying
himself and
that was probably the more impressive
part and 2011 like at the world at his
feed he was exciting it was called kind
of like that carlos spencer sort of vibe
first sort of influencer in that rugby
sort of space and everyone's paying
attention to what he's wearing and how
he's acting and sort of how he probably
handled that he's probably not the same
person that he is today so the evolution
of kuwait is is something to be proud of
and proud to call him a friend right
that's so cool it's so cool to see
someone like that do that full circle
because like you said no one wanted him
for a while there he's come around and
he seems to really have grown as a
person and you can see that his foot has
improved because of it yeah and he's
like
like even though he's like famous he's
he's a low-key dude like he hangs around
he hangs on his little brother
um and dill bran who looks after his
like photography and stuff like he's
he's not he's not out there drinking he
doesn't drink any stuff anymore
loves being around his family loves
providing for his family but quade's
always been that guy he's always loved
to have people in and around him
a lot of our friends when when he moved
to brisbane and he started to make it
like a lot of our friends that we grew
up with used to go live with him and
then go live with him for free never
asking for anything i was always looking
after people and sort of stuff like that
so that's probably the side equate that
a lot of people don't see they see
driving a g-wagon and rocking cool [ __ ]
and hanging around there and he's
[ __ ] cool
um but behind all that sort of that
instagram persona is that there's a big
heart there and he's always been like
that he's always been um like he's
always kind of like the leader of the
group as well so people sort of
gravitate towards him um so him knocking
over their kick is nothing it's just a
just a byproduct of the person that he
is right now and it's great to see it
and great to see him get some
recognition of the back of it yeah so
cool so you grew up with um quaid you
grew up with sure maitland couple of
kiwi legends and lads um so how come you
went down the league path instead of
follow those two down the rugby path my
dad was just a pure league he hated
rugby
but we also had a league town so we have
two league teams in our hometown and
kind of just won now we had two back in
the day but it's kind of merged into one
so a lot of those smaller towns around
the waikato area are kind of more league
dominant even like you used to have
league teams and then um huntley have a
couple teams not a wahia um have turned
huawei and the panthers and like you
know what i mean so
um
more blue color in around those areas
but
yeah we're kind of league towns in
my dad was my coach since we were six to
16 along with quade like i supply half
and quade used to play first five or
five eight um but we like from six to
sixteen i reckon we would have lost
about maybe six games all up true yeah
so and i like i can remember every loss
that we had in teams and what age we
were because it didn't happen too often
so we were kind of that crew that had a
bunch of mates
um and we all grew up together and
played together and my dad used to take
do like broncos training camps and stuff
like that like online courses and stuff
and we used to be running bronco plays
and stuff like 10 so we were pretty
advanced uh but i set us up pretty well
for football later on and like
he obviously moved over to kuwait
obviously moved over to uh churchy and
brisbane brisbane because he went to
queensland when he's like 13 for a year
killed it come back played with us and
then ended up getting a scholarship
there but then by then like me and my
other friend tom's like we were like 14
15 and we're playing like open men's so
we're very advanced and obviously you
have to go up pretty quick as well you
start drinking with the boys when you're
14 15 and hang around parties and stuff
like that so yeah um yeah it's a good
place to grow up and was pro footy the
dream even from that age obviously if
you're playing at that level at 14
you're probably
thinking you're probably going to go
pretty far oh i was my bro my first game
when i was 14 like i went to go watch my
older brother play he was about 18 at
the time
and uh we played odo
and if you know if you know the color
region is well known for like monkey mob
so and we were kind of like a black
power town so i remember rocking up and
i was short of half and like i was
obviously pretty confident in myself and
i was like [ __ ] i'm just going to jump
on played well and stuff but i remember
just guys having like bulldogs on their
face and stuff like that
and one of my mates he was running and
he was about 18 as well and he stepped
the sky and
the this mongol mob dude just swipe
kicked him like didn't even try and get
like proper like mma he kicked him
flipped him upside down
and then his mom some come running on
and he i remember this muggle mum guy
just kind of [ __ ] you i'll [ __ ] you up
and i was like oh [ __ ] like i really
shouldn't be here
but yeah i was i was a confident kid
trying to do chip and chases and [ __ ]
like that
wasn't making much tackles though i'll
just put it that way
did you ever get involved in gangs or
anything nah no no quaid was a bit of a
gangster when we were younger
i i had really good parents um yeah
obviously i was in and around me like we
were one of those towns where you
couldn't wear a colour and now we
couldn't wear red true so if you're all
red you
have to get into a fight basically um
but no i wasn't wasn't part of like
no i wasn't i wasn't nowhere near that
sort of stuff it was in and around me uh
when i was five years old my rep coach
was my uncle and he was in the black
power and i've talked about the story on
the tudor advocate actually
and um he gave me his key and i remember
this vividly he gave me his key and then
he goes go behind the grandstand at the
local ground and open up the boot so i
was like oh i call like five years just
do what you're told open up the boot
and um then him and his two guys come
running around the corner they flipped
up the mat and there was like baseball
bats underneath there as well and then
these two like my mom's coming around
the corner i understand you're like five
years old my mom's like get over here
get over here and the boys are just
having to swing at each other with
baseball bats so
um like it was in and around me but i
just knew that wasn't me and in our
hometown like my dad for example
everyone works in the mill i just like
oh just looking at that mule and can
leave what should we call it is my
biggest motivation to get out um and i
just saw sports as my way out and then
you got signed by the warriors i think
you're only 18 when you got signed by
the warriors so mate you were you were a
wizard at a young age um yeah so i
signed a paramedic when i was like 14 15
as well so in my school holidays i used
to come over here and do camps and um
and like hainese was the guy that i used
to stay oh like just how's the scope
um he used to have a house where the
boys used to come stay um i didn't stay
in their house but i used to always be
over their house because they were kiwi
and i could sort of relate to them as
well
so i guess
i was coming to sydney probably four
times a year to do training camps and
stuff and then um the 20s was going to
launch and tony ira was a cook island
guy and um sort of knew i could play a
bit and so that's how i got signed to
the warriors went from high school to
training full-time so it's pretty
interesting and then the toyota cap had
just formed two around that stage too i
remember watching the warriors under 20s
play and seeing a young like stacy jones
coming through the ranks and in the form
of yourself
what was it like playing in that
competition yeah it was cool um like i
got to play premier league the year
before so and then we were the first
year of 20s and like when i look back on
our sound side now we were loaded so i
think like 15 of our starting 17 went on
to go play nrl so we had a really good
side and i got done in the semi-finals
to a pretty good brisbane side never
should have got done but um
yeah it was cool bro it was like that
weekend week out sort of grind we're on
telly a lot so it was kind of like we
had this like bit of fame about us which
was like weird yeah um which is good and
a bad thing but yeah it was cool like
really enjoyed everything about that
obviously had some really great coaches
and then sort of just progressed from
there and fast tracked into the warriors
the following year what was it like
going into that environment obviously
pretty lots of legends in this side
so like yeah not 2009 was a weird yeah
because obviously we come off the back
of 20s and then we rolled into like a
premier league comp that wasn't as like
because 20s had come taken over like you
just kind of playing on random parks
again
so when i when the week before i debuted
like we had a buy for our premier league
cup but then i had to go back down
another level to play odaho cup like
play for odahu and box memorial yeah so
i went from playing foxtrot memorial
then debuting against the roosters and
um stacey jones was my half back so it
was pretty [ __ ] trippy man we ended
up winning and i only played like three
games that year
but it was a good year sort of next year
we
come in and we won five or six games in
a row which was like pretty exciting for
me at the time and got resigned off the
back of that but ended up doing my acl
the same year so um big big seven
deceiver took a dive at my leg and got
me so
that'll do it brutal
but did you feel confident when you got
your chance to play for the warriors did
you always feel comfortable in the
environment or not really yeah i was one
of those players bro so if you watch me
play like reggie's and that like i
probably wouldn't stand out too much but
then as i as like i got higher and
higher like i was able to control things
around me a lot better um like the
higher the bigger the game i was always
a lot better even in 20s fine i think in
the 20s final ski series i scored like
five or six tries or setting them up
flat
like um and then rolled into first grade
my debut i set up a really good try
and then when i come back to penrith and
when i was actually focused on football
which is the other part of the equation
um i was
the bigger the game i always got better
so i was always confident i could do
something but i was kind of injury
plagued as well so
um and that's just what is what it is
and i'm grateful for those injuries now
because it sort of pushed me towards
that reading so michael who's like the
og um toilet back in the day and yeah
right number three for the warriors he
was very unassuming like you'd look at
him and you're like [ __ ] he must be the
dumbest can't because his head's always
in the wrong place he's always stitched
up but then you had a conversation with
him outside of it like i always go for
coffees and i always hung around the
older boys jake lilyman was my roommate
so them two had this little
townsville connection so he's hanging
around those boys and like you talk to
him bro he's so interesting like diverse
on so many different levels um could
talk about everything and he he
introduced me to my first couple books
while i had an acl and obviously i done
well in school as well so reading wasn't
like a chore for me but i really started
to enjoy it and sort of just
yeah it sort of grew from there just
really love reading off the back of that
that's cool and that's and that's sort
of how you sort of learnt the whole sort
of business side of things from those
injuries was it was that when you
started looking ahead for life after
ugly um i used to like jump on like 2010
i was jumping like how can i make money
online i was answering these types of
questions
but yeah it was more so that your
reading progression like you start
reading things that you're interested
about so um i was reading about uh the
tour de france and and lance armstrong
and stuff like that because i was on the
bike every single day so i wanted to
know reading about boxing so i'd read
mike tyson's then you gravitate from
like autobiographies and to
self-development so the secret was kind
of a big thing at the time you kind of
get bored of that you move into business
and then i found myself reading books
about business or entrepreneurs or
talking to guys like that had friends in
the business space that were just
traveling to la for a couple days like i
just thought that was so sick
and that made my
my stomach was like getting more excited
about that than football and now i kind
of knew that was my time to transition
obviously this is a lot later in life
yeah read about 100 books by then but i
found my interest peaking in different
and different things
um yeah just kind of gravitated towards
that after so you mentioned before
around
when you put your mind to sort of the
footage what was your league lifestyle
like were you were you a hard trainer or
you're pretty cruisy sort of guy um so
early on i was a very hard trainer
because like i loved football yeah i
used to watch all the time i was like um
i can talk about football really well
because i really enjoyed video sessions
and i talked to assistant coaches and i
just really enjoyed have you watched
mighty ducks
no i love you long long time ago
so like there's a guy named charlie
conway and like he like he's an okay
player but he he makes like a better
coach like he sort of sacrif i always
thought i was going to be like him like
i always thought i was going to
gravitate towards coaching because i
enjoyed the x's and o's and about it um
so obviously when things were going well
for me like i was off the piss
like i was studying i was learning about
the game mostly often do my own training
camps and stuff not not train on my own
but there's a guy named keegan smith who
um he's pretty well known because he
trained sonny bill yeah he used to be
the roosters trainer so i used to be
like inquisitive about like reading
about nutrition about all the sort of
stuff i would go up to byron bay and do
three day camps and stuff like that i
was kind of that guy because i knew i
wasn't i had basic talent or like above
average talent but i knew i just wasn't
like a shawnee johnson or a kevin locke
or someone that could just rock up in a
day and do something special i was one
of those guys that had to tick all the
boxes yeah and when i was doing that i
was playing really good football like
obviously you got to play test football
come back and play against the warriors
called a hat-trick um all that sort of
stuff and that's taking all the boxes
outside the field and the other side of
it as well like i was always kind of
like the boys boy as well i loved being
in group chats and whatsapp groups and
and loved having a beer on the weekend
and all that sort of stuff as well but
that sort of is how yktr started i hung
around two boys i'd love to get on the
piss and yeah i was one of those guys as
well so
um yeah there was two parts to me when i
was ticking boxes i was playing really
good football i was never a superstar i
was never going to be um but could do a
really good job for you and have an
influence on the result and then there's
the other side where i'd be going out on
the weekend and you'll start thinking
[ __ ] wonder why my foot is going down
and that's probably the reason why
so you mentioned your um obviously your
game against the warriors when you'd
moved to the panthers uh
absolute clinic three tries was it was
that sort of the game of your career
yeah easily um it's just like
sometimes you hear about players or
artists and they talk about that that
flow state or their state of flow and
it's like you can't really remember it
that's that's what that game was like
like i don't like only reason i remember
it was because people show me highlights
every year when it pops up yeah like i
don't i don't remember the lead up to
the only thing i remember is ivan on
captain's run going just treated like an
another game and the only thing i
remember after the game is goes you
won't get that every week that's another
yeah that 24 hours between that like i
don't literally don't remember it so i'd
love to sit here and go yeah like i've
seen things like super clear and yeah
was any watermelons or the hoop look
like that big like i wish i could say
that stuff but it just wouldn't be true
i know i know it made good micro content
i get that
i literally don't remember it bro i
don't remember a thing about it and on
the back of that game you get called
into the kiwis which was probably a
little bit of a shock what was it like
finding out that you'd made the kiwis
i'm actually it was actually the year
after so i strung together a pretty good
13 um played the whole season there and
then the next year was weird so we just
signed peter wallace and jamie salad so
they got first crack at five eight yeah
and i was kind of in and out the first
six weeks and then i actually made the
kiwis from reserve grade that's right so
i yeah i
dropped back to reserve grade um not by
form just out of circumstance because
the boys are back in and then so i was
playing reserve grade and then i got
called into the kiwis from there so it
reminded me of that time i played for
odahu and then next man i was playing
for [ __ ] nrl so um i wasn't flustered
by it but um yeah like i really enjoyed
the experience eh
we got like 40k you know i got 40k for
that game i
remember a jackpot no wonder he was
confident and stoked
yeah 100 and i come off the bench as
well so it was the first time i'd ever
come off the bench first time i'd ever
played like a
test match and we we actually went right
we had a pretty young side and everyone
was riding us off [ __ ] funny story
actually so i didn't think i was going
to make it so i played on a saturday i
rolled into the casino i got home at
five with team fidei and dean fighter
was always going to make it it was a
friday game yeah so
we got caught into camp we had to go to
chinatown and we stayed in the hotel but
i hung over as [ __ ] didn't think i was
going to make it
and i roll into a camp and then i sit
down and have brekkie and on the back
page it's like me versus thurston so
thurston's the 6-4 yeah
i'm the sixth and they'll compare in our
last couple games
so they're like oh ice is on um 120k and
thurston's worth a million dollars and
then ice is next game he's playing
reserve grade up in cessnock
and i'm just sitting there like hungover
stuff like this and looking at that and
then we went out for dinner and um
stephen cleary stephen kearney was our
coach
and he goes all right boys everyone just
have a couple beers tonight it'd be good
and like i literally couldn't need
because i was too hung over yeah and he
goes well are you going to eat as like
well i can't bro like all [ __ ] spewed
up because why is that it goes i'm just
hung over to be honest i didn't think i
was going to make it
so yeah that was the start of my key
weekend but um even in that game went
good like i said a little bit earlier
like as the games got bigger i feel like
i could always rise to occasion if you
watch me play down on park footy you'll
be like [ __ ] who's this dad
so is that quite common to just go out
on the piss before camps and stuff like
that or is that sort of a league thing
yeah uh
you would have been back in the day yeah
like ivan was kind of
like if you lose if we lost three games
at the warriors all right boys
everyone's on the piss on a monday
that's right and like training yeah
everyone there like the coaches will
come for the first four or five yeah um
training will stay with us we'll have a
few beers everyone home by midnight
we're there about two o'clock in the
afternoon
beauty week so that was kind of the
culture i don't think it's like that
anymore no not definitely not anymore
but
um that was a sunday night so um
kearney's like oh first night in camp
let's have a couple beers together like
nothing crazy bro like four or five
beers and a bit of dinner and that's
about it but back in the day was a vibe
bro it's crazy monday monday he's coming
up in ponsonby just getting blind
growls i went around too so you can't
really get in trouble yeah no social
media back then really was there or was
there ah oh starting like facebook yeah
myspace
it's old we are bro bibo
that was good
mate and then the next move was to manly
i know so so i went to uk after thing
but [ __ ] [ __ ] that um so what
happened there what happened in the uk
oh just i signed a three-year contract
and it kind of just fell out with the
coach out of nowhere um and there was a
weird coach like he was technically he
was very sound but he was kind of going
for a divorce and stuff at the same time
so some days you'd be sweet and you made
next day you're [ __ ] walking on
eggshells around them and sure like snap
just snappy so when you come from like
tony ira and um ivan cleary who's like
laid back and well they don't waste
words and you go into this guy who's
going like you [ __ ] stand up like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here in
video you feel like you're in the
assembly intermediate in trouble so um
just very different styles and just kind
of fell out with the like coach and he
just goes he pulled me in the office one
time and he goes no matter how well you
play i'll never play you again or no
matter how well you train i don't care
and i still had two and a half years on
my contract oh wow so just sitting there
like i was 21. i was going
what like you've got me over here like
stuff like this and like they were
playing really good football without me
um and i was just like oh cool that's
what it is
um then he used to try and give me all
the [ __ ] jobs bro so obviously with i
understand it's now within business it's
like you try and smoke someone out the
business by applying pressure
like a business tactic that you use
that's what he was trying to do to me so
i had to be at training at five and with
the fat club like training and i was
killing i was just training harder and
harder and like he could like yeah i was
rocking out for a smile on my face like
he couldn't get rid of me i'll just go
yeah [ __ ] it i'll be going i'd be at the
end of the year anyway but the best
thing about it was like my back was
against the wall and i started training
hard as and by the time i got back to
penrith which was round one of the 2013
season i was probably in the best shape
i'd ever been and i was kind of like out
of spite as well
but
my first day at penrith training was
like my last day in yorkshire was it was
one of the coldest days in yorkshire it
was like minus 13. i jumped on the 48
hour like i trained that day like i was
in a dinner suit i was like [ __ ]
looking energy for these guns
um train that day jumped on the plane
that night and i was like 36 hours
before i landed
in penrith and i got put up in this
random hotel i was there for a week had
to figure out a place to stay i rocked
up the training of the first day and it
was the last little touch-up before
round one
and like i was like it's like 45 degrees
so i've gone from like mine to
jet lagged 45 and i've i've told over i
was like don't worry about like i'm best
shaped because you'd see me trying out
the warriors and i like i used to get
the highest and the bp's and stuff
um it's like me and mannering at the end
like
arsenal nelson boyd
um and like so he knew he knew i was fit
and then i was going oh bro i'm fitter
than i was at the warriors trust me and
i rocked up and i was in good shape but
it's just the obviously the time
difference and [ __ ] humidity
[Music]
um but it set me up like i rocked up and
played about four or five games of um
reserve grade and rolled into first
grade and done a good job but yeah that
manly um i think that half mentally at
the half checked out i just hadn't
admitted it to myself trim barrel was my
coach and we got along real well um i
was just like oh bro can i just come
manly with you for a year just see how i
go i never said that i was looking at
retiring um but i just knew
like
like i was i was going to mainly give
them the best to be honest yeah so um at
the time i'd read a bunch of different
books we toyed with the idea of why ktr
um i've just done a bunch of traveling
i've just come off the back of six weeks
of traveling we went to bali new york
texas la for six weeks bro and i just
got back to train i was like
i'd rather be doing that than being here
yeah um
that's when a big transition started to
change and had a few injuries there and
the last one was i tore my pack
and i remember going to the change room
and go [ __ ] i'm over football like this
is the first time i said it out loud
um and i just go [ __ ] i think i'm gonna
retire and it was just me in the change
room and i was like as soon as i said it
bro it's just
felt like 10 times lighter and like
obviously when i look back now i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's pretty scary to sort of
leave something that you've always known
but at the time i just knew something
was pulling me away and
i knew if i hung around football
i wasn't going to be happy and and trim
baron had offered me um a coaching gig
there so i could have coached the 20s
and then he goes you'll be my assistant
later yeah and that's
what i always thought i was going to
head into coaching i thought i would be
really good at it um but i just had
something else pulling me this other way
and sort of glad i followed it mate
that's crazy crazy that you had the
coaching gigs everything set out your
your life after 40 sorted but you chased
the dream of doing what you want to do
that's so cool yeah and yeah and like
able to inspire a lot more people by
what i'm doing i obviously didn't know i
was gonna be sitting here and it's like
[ __ ] nice office of staff and [ __ ]
like that but um every time my gut's
like dropped
after football i've always sort of
followed it like let's start vlogging
like let's start a podcast like let's
start yktr sports um do multiple other
things on the other side and i've always
sort of followed that gut instinct and
it's kind of a weird thing to talk about
but it's always sort of steered me in
the right direction so cool do you look
back at your footy career and think
you would have done anything differently
if you had another if you had another
crack at it um yeah so i feel like me
and scott were talking about it's like
like it's the same thing with business
so in sports you're measured by
scoreboards and business you're measured
by money yeah whenever i'm doing
something and whenever i'm ticking the
boxes i'm going for runs i'm working out
i'm eating all the right things i'm
reading books and stuff like this like
our business goes like that
it means where your sports does so i
wish i knew what i knew back then but
then on in the other breath i'm glad
things went that way is because us like
i'm 32 i might have just been retiring
like a year and a half ago or a year or
might be in england trying to [ __ ]
scratch for a deal you know what i mean
so um
now i'm grateful for the way things
worked out my injuries were the favor my
best part of my career because it led me
to reading um me partying with the boys
lead me to yktr so
everything happens for a reason and
um let's just put it this way if
if wayne bennett come through and
offered me like a three-year contract on
[ __ ] 500k a year i'd happily turn it
down yeah and because the position i'm
in right now i'd rather be right here um
i control my own destiny i control what
my days look like
i can travel whenever i want obviously
besides covert i can do whatever i want
bro and that type of freedom is is is
exciting to me when you're in football
bro it's like like be here wear this
yeah say this make sure you're the
airport by this time oh you're in front
of media don't say this like get to this
corner
if we do if we complete it 35 uh 35 sets
out of 40 with a good chance of winning
don't do that
so you and at [ __ ] you after football
because you're so used to being told
what to do especially if you've gone
from school to football
once you get out you think you're
chasing freedom bro but you're actually
not like you actually crave that routine
again so like i left football and i was
like oh this is going to be the best i'm
just going to get on the piers and then
sleep in and then after about a month or
two i'm like [ __ ] i'm like scattered i
didn't know what to do so it sort of
restructured my life how how it been my
whole life and nine o'clock do this 10
o'clock do this and i felt my life a lot
better off the back of that true man
that's so so cool to hear so did you
your plan was your plan always to get
into sort of the content creation sort
of thing or how did you sort of get into
where you are now um so when i was at
wakefield we used to do this thing so we
had three teams within your sports team
um with our footy team and like
obviously say there's 30 in your squad
there was 10 in each squad and then they
you had to make it like a parody style
video and then present it and then loser
had to dance in front of everyone that
was just kind of like the thing that
they did
and just because i was a new guy there
richard agar made me like the leader and
then i i filmed like my very first vlog
and like it was compared to the boys it
was elite like the the thought of angles
and the sounding and like i learned how
to edit on the spot there
um started doing that
or used to watch a lot of youtube as
well i was speaking to vice and there
used to be a
nate robinson
youtube thing called state of nate and
we still watch it all the time so me and
chico just done like our own version of
that that was kind of like my second
vlog
but i just found when i was traveling i
just wanted to do videos and take photos
and like people look at kaitlyn now and
think he's like the coolest dude um
taking photos when i was doing i was
getting paid like i was a footy guy that
read books and took photos and
i'm gonna talk about different [ __ ] and
i was [ __ ] weird you're ahead of your
time so
yeah i know that's why i tell the boys i
[ __ ] paved the way for you
um i was just those types of interesting
like walking around and learning how to
edit on the camera oh take photos and
like manual and shoot content and
read books and do online courses i was
always kind of into that stuff because
that was the stuff that interests me but
i never knew
content was going to be the thing i knew
i could make it but
i found when i started listening to gary
vee um he said like each clothing brand
should have a vlog or each clothing
brand should have a podcast and was a
big part of everything that we've done
like i started vlogging i'm glad i did
because people like oh you're lucky
you're there now because you know
football players like i go back to like
vlog number one on youtube and you'll
see me [ __ ] about to cry on
[ __ ]
stressful as [ __ ] yeah i bet and close
so so why why sort of clothes because
i've heard you say before you don't even
really like clothes but why'd you go
down the clothes route instead of uh
another sort of product i just felt like
it was the easiest thing to do it just
had an easy entrance point like you
could like anyone could start a clothing
brand today like it's not hard to go
down and um put four letters on a
t-shirt
and i was just kind of there so we're
going out heaps and we'll just like why
ktl was just something we used to sound
like yours accounts like you know the
rules and it kind of just stuck because
it looked a little bit weird like even
when i say like when people go what's
why ktr stand for and i say you know the
rules they still go like kind of had
this little catchy thing about it and
then we printed it on a t-shirt one time
i was like oh that looks kind of cool
and we're going for general pants and
like i feel like our stuff looks better
than this so it was just kind of that
inquisitive thing about it um but it
just felt easy like i know a lot of
people got clothing brands right now but
there wasn't anyone that we could look
to that was like it reminded me coming
from toke when there was no nrl players
from there yeah i was just like
[ __ ] why can't we do that and it was
kind of more that inquisitive thing as
well and obviously we started making
them and we're selling them to our like
footy mates for like 20 bucks and we're
like what the [ __ ] we're killing it
we're killing that yeah and then we kind
of just grew off the back of that as
well and it's not like i was into
clothes at the time i was into shoes
um like i used to have like 80 pairs of
shoes and used to like line up online so
i was into clothes at the time yeah i
think i've gravitated away from that but
uh yeah i just i just thought it'd be i
thought it would be cool when you walk
past someone and they're wearing your
brand like i thought that'd have been
cool at the time and obviously get to
see now but um that was just
that was just kind of like the easiest
business i could think of to be honest
and now everyone's wearing it it's uh
it's taken over it's taking over
australia
it's on absolute fire so it's it's crazy
how you sort of um still blown away with
how you sort of had this contract to um
do
be a nrl coach or have a progression
into that uh set up but then you sort of
gam you gamble because obviously you
didn't know you're going to be making
money from clothes or like enough to
sort of live off or how did you sort of
survive that first period did you have
money saved up or did you have
investments or what was the sort of go
there no no
so it was kind of weird like the day
that my contract finished was that day
that my house cleared so i bought a
house off the plan two years before when
i was at penrith so i went from manly
which is like a beautiful part of the
world all the way back out to penrith um
so
and then i just had a house in a two
bedroom i was like oh cool just put yktr
all the clothes in that spare bedroom
and we'll try and grow from there and um
i had a bit of savings behind me but it
just went like that and
yeah
and like i was struggling for like oh no
do you know what i actually played park
football um i was getting paid a
thousand dollars a game to play reserve
grade oh yeah [ __ ]
the most lackluster effort you would
ever see from a problem
like people looking like this come play
kiwis nobody on the line there
no no no and the thing was bro like you
had to i had to pay for my own health
insurance over here oh sure
that's
so used to it just being paid for me
yeah and like couldn't afford to pay the
150 a month because they're just like
i was paying off a mortgage and it was
only interest only and i was like trying
to get by on food and stuff
so i made a decision not to pay the
interest i mean the the insurance and
then [ __ ]
dinner suit straight on like never in
the line
making [ __ ] all tackles because i knew
if i got injured i wouldn't be able to
post all my ktr stuff
so but you should have seen how far back
i was playing from the line i just knew
i knew if i got injured let's go [ __ ] my
yktr thing because i was the guy i was i
was hand packing everything i was
building all the websites i was doing
all that sort of stuff as well i kind of
just had money but i was getting by like
i wish i i think i still got the photos
it should be in my cloud like i remember
going to the supermarket with like gold
coins in my hands
and it was like i was like 14 to 15 in
gold coins that i'd found and i was like
[ __ ] i need to get food for the next
week and like stuff like that so you're
going from getting paid this is an nrl
player whacking through all your savings
trying to pay off a mortgage um
you think you need because everyone's
told you that you need to buy a house or
you should have a house by the time you
finish football yeah and to walk into
the supermarket
[ __ ] what can i get for this it was mad
like i'm not saying that bro like i
could have gone to my mom and gone hey
mom like [ __ ] need some money like
she would send me some money yeah yeah
um it wasn't like do or die
but also
before things started to get really good
i'm not not even great like um my
my power got cut off so when you're
running an e-commerce business and you
you need power so i was down the bottom
of my house and where i support my car
it was a brand new house
there was a power point right by my car
yeah so i could go down there plug it in
and then sprung my ktr from an iphone
down there
power got cut off used to have to drive
to the post office to do all my
deliveries and stuff cars smart like car
engine blew up it's like a 5 000 fix i
was like nowhere near that like type of
money
um and it just it was just kind of like
i knew if i got through that period i
could get through anything
and
um that was just my time where i had no
power for two weeks i was just having
cold showers and then saying that
natasha who works for me now
she lived across the road had this
beautiful house you guys come over you
can have internet hot showers and stuff
like that yeah like i said like i sound
like i'm doing a tough air but i was
putting myself in those situations as
well because i knew
if i go out and have a hot shower i'm
just taking like the easy way out that
was kind of the way that i saw it
and then um we started to go alright
like i started vlogging and we started
going to write and i got my first pay as
yktr and it was like 35 000 a year that
was like my first pay
and that was like i think it was like
450 a week and i was
i think my interest only loan was like
300 bucks a week oh yeah and that [ __ ]
and honestly when i've got that i'm
clear that with the boys like
i said before that i made forty thousand
dollars playing one game of football and
at 35 000 has felt like the most money
i've ever made in my whole life and in a
position now where i've got multiple
streams and doing and doing good things
and buying bitcoin and [ __ ] like that um
i've i've never been more excited than i
was driving home that day and making 35k
a year 450 bucks a week or something
like that i was like [ __ ] i made it
yeah did you ever get to the point where
you felt like it was too much you were
gonna you're gonna give up on it or no
yeah yeah a couple times like um
i just i was i put myself under so much
stress like i got rid of my tv like if i
wasn't like working on ykt i was online
courses i was books i was like i was up
till like two in the morning like i get
up at i got up at 2 30 this morning i
used to be upset morning um then i'd
sleep at five i had this weird thing
that i was going to get outworked you
know what i mean so there's a really
important part that i had to go through
and the reason why we could sit here
today is because i went through that
time yeah but also like i just put way
too much pressure on myself and i was
just stressful i was angry i was snappy
um i remember looking back and like
people like we sold out something but i
remember like almost crying like cause i
was just so tired and like but that back
in the days like when we used to sell
out i was like [ __ ] have to pack like
a couple hundred orders tomorrow
i associate that as like the pre-season
of like if you go through that you can
set yourself up for a little bit later
and that was just kind of a little eight
to nine month preseason mate that's
inspiring stuff from the bottom as drake
once said what start at the bottom now
you're here
what a what a journey but you and also
your podcast as well you've got one of
the great podcasts on the
on the market at the moment the ice
project so when did that sort of start
yeah i was just i was um probably about
a year after we started vlogging like we
had an office in parramatta and i just
found myself having really interesting
conversations with a lot of people i
feel like i could always speak really
really well and and um
like a lot of people used to say very
unassuming because i'd be like a like a
islander from tokura that plays football
and i'd sit in conversation i could have
a diverse conversation so i just kind of
wanted to evolve from that i just wanted
to interview people
um the main reason i've done it bro is
because like if if someone comes asking
me hey bro can i buy you a coffee if i
can pick your brain for an hour like i
should kind of be there guys okay bro
can i come spend time with you because i
want to learn from you yeah but what you
learn about podcasts and everyone's
favorite subject is themselves like i'm
like oh what a lad like he's a good pod
like
basically i'm just talking about myself
and it makes me feel good and i knew
that so
when i interview people i get them
talking about themselves and then um i
could sort of build a network off the
back of that so that was kind of the
main reason done today like
it's it's easier to get someone on the
podcast than it is to spend an hour of
them asking them if you can buy them a
coffee because essentially you're saying
that something's worth four bucks yeah
so that's that's how like successful
people see it they're like oh i can make
a thousand bucks in an hour why i'm
going to go spend four bucks yeah listen
to another guy in a clothing brand so um
that was sort of the main reason um but
i just needed more content as well
mate that's so cool and yktr you talk
about more content yktr sports has
formed and changing sports media one of
the one of the coolest things what was
the idea behind this one um
i heard myself like i was complaining
about fox sports a lot um talking guys
about nrl's 360 and stuff like that and
i remember listening back to the loop on
the micro clip and i said god they
should be doing those this and then i
remember hearing it back and i said but
if you're not going to do anything like
shut the [ __ ] up like you know what i
mean
it was kind of one of those moments and
my nan had passed away
um and i was flying back this way and i
had no i remember my phone going flat
and i just had to always carry like a
blank pad and pen just whenever i have
ideas write down or write down new
business models and stuff like that and
i had three hours on a plane where i
don't really watch movies on planes and
stuff as well i just like to sit there
and think and stuff like that and it was
kind of built off the back of that where
i was just like oh if you're not gonna
do anything about it like how can we
change it and we started looking at
different business models like
basketball sports and complex and and um
bleacher report and stuff like that
i just felt like you could do better i
just felt like we could
as a country we could be better in terms
of packaging up this product that we
have in rugby league
and distributed out to fans in a
different way and i've seen the success
that we've had off the back of yktr or
so [ __ ] why can't i do this for more
people or why can't we bring in more
talent and change it and to be honest
it's changed a lot bro we're initially
going to be like a complex style we'll
create our own shows and it might be
like a sneaker shopping or hot ones or
like we kind of want to do that content
and we
we will but because we covered we will
come unlimited so we just went full
podcast mode so
that's the idea behind it we've got some
pretty cool projects coming up in the
next couple weeks that you'll probably
see where we're trying to hit down um
obviously can't talk about them too much
now yeah but then off to back that it
just build a better relationship between
players and fans because right now
there's this big media war that dictates
narrative and we just want to break that
down and it should be direct to fan um i
think sean johnson probably does it well
best at the moment like i thought we
were going to be the company and they're
like
all right surely going back to warriors
like him he'll want to come speak to us
before he goes to speak to but the best
way to do it is just go direct yeah like
everyone's got a social media account
and probably shawn he does does it the
best bro yeah like he's self-aware now
he's a little bit more mature he's older
i mean he articulates himself well so if
if he hears rumors about him he'll just
jump on hey guys
hearing rumors and that's the way it
should be yeah you should let the media
dictate your own narrative so
um but i think we've had a
minor influence on how people operate
now but i just want to scale it out and
there's a few different business models
you can build off the back of it but i
think we can be a big player in the
space pretty soon no doubt and you talk
about like the player brands sean
johnson's player brand etc what do you
think players need to do to sort of grow
their brand especially these young guys
coming through what's what advice would
you have for these guys um there's a
couple guys that i'm kind of tied with
now from new zealand that will probably
reference um tj perenna yeah does it
really well yeah lavia and aaron smith
and those are the three guys that are
probably in my dms more than anyone else
um like for guys that are super
successful like ardy's just gone on to
captain um the all blacks and aaron's
played over 100 games and tj is doing
this thing as well he's back in there
man the types of questions that they ask
them move like a little bit differently
and the way that my
my
answer to that would be maximize your
leverage right now but maximize your
leverage in the right way like don't
don't use your leverage to skip a line
and get a coffee or get a free line of
kombucha or come to yktr go hey bro i've
got [ __ ] 5 000 followers give me some
clothes yeah maximize it and the point
where right now you're relevant and
people are interested in what you and
what you what you want to see and what
you want to do or what you're doing in
your everyday life that's that's the
catch like a lot of people think they
want to see the 80 minutes at the end
now like what's rika iwani like what's
he eating at macas on the drive through
that's content yeah or what's he doing a
day off like that's content um
what are the boys talking about when
they go from field to weights
that's that's where the beauty part of
content is right now and and that's why
reality shows are really popular and
people like myself can create vlogs so
people are actually interested in your
everyday life and it's not so much about
the training it's not so much about the
football because we see the polished
product at the end we see the 80 minutes
um bro what's [ __ ] aaron smith doing
on tuesday
and and that's that's how i see content
so um i'd be
creating my own content in some way
shape or form whether it be podcast
vlogging q a's are really important
create a touch point with your fan base
build a community and then later on you
can add a product um we call that
product to market fit so you as you're
in all black you've got the ultimate
leverage and it's just like how do i
maximize this but do it in a way that
um
that's positive that can make a change
um and once you get that dm hyper you've
changed my life man actually becomes
euphoric and it gets addictive and you
just want more of it bro so you start to
gravitate towards that and you'll find
you can monetize it sooner or later
through some way shape or form and like
i've mentioned those boys as well we've
kind of got a business model that we're
potentially going to chase next year
i think it's going to be really cool and
i think it could really work so yeah
that's types of converse i'm having at
the moment made exciting times and
another thing around that space is nfts
i'm pretty keen to hear your thoughts on
nfts and how that's gonna come into the
game of rugby and rugby league um it's
gonna take a while i don't think there's
a do you own any bitcoin or any
cryptocurrency i've got crypto yeah yeah
bitcoin eve yeah cool so like in this in
this office where i i'm like hey boys
getting like i've been saying this since
like february board games group are
getting crypto probably the boys
collectively would only have about two
thousand dollars worth of crypto in
there you know what i mean and yeah um
we just don't have that full adoption of
it as well in terms of entities i think
it's going to be a big space moving
forward um i think all tickets are going
to be sold through that as well so
imagine having a like and you know who
used to put tickets behind
like i was at the 2011 grand final when
yeah beaver had that that can become an
nft pretty soon but the way i sort of
see it in players sort of space and i've
talked about this before um let's use
audi server he's probably the most
forward-thinking
athlete in new zealand right now so he
could sell an eft every single year and
say like a gold standard one would be
worth
say say he's a hundred nfts and the gold
ones worth twenty thousand dollars so
instead of a business going to sponsor
the hurricanes um because they love
sarvia potentially they could sponsor
adi as a gold nft for twenty thousand
dollars but as a part of that token um
adi's gonna give you two um you can do
two campaigns with him throughout the
year you get invited to his networking
space and dinners and the other guys
that have four if the other
four holders of those gold nfts you get
a networking opportunities and you get
to like you know i mean you start to
think about that
you tear it down to like a silver
version and silver version might get you
a signed jersey from a blessed slow cup
game and you get to rock up to a game
and that's fifteen thousand dollars
um then you go down there then you just
have all these different levels of
tokens and you can level it out like
that and and in that way a player can
maximize the potential of his own brand
without taking too much away from um
unless you like ad sponsors and and all
that sort of stuff like that so
i think that's going to be the way
forward and then that's when you'll see
guys and this is why i'm talking about
content right now so like you create
your content oh you start liking every
comment that's hey bro thank you thank
you thank you um thanks for coming to
the game appreciate you guys all that
sort of stuff hey guys i'm just in the
locker room after the game let's go have
a quick chat you build that community
you build that trust and when you drop
that product and as an nft you're going
to have a you can make
a bit of money and then you can also
create like um make a change as well and
the fun thing about nfts bro once you
build them into a smart contract you can
have royalties off the back of that as
well so you might have a fan that's
bought a 100 nft and then say rd's form
starts going up
yeah um and
you know i mean and that nft is worth
potentially 200 now if he sells that to
that person id can get a clip back on
the royalties as well
so
it's interesting yeah it is it's still a
while off
do you think you have to be an all black
or what level would you would you start
looking at at it say you're a like young
19 year old prodigy would you even get
into that space or do you think you need
to be more elite um obviously the more
elite guy is going to get the bigger
deals it's the same way with sponsorship
like
aaron smith probably gets a better
adidas deal than i would ever would
because he's a [ __ ] hundred tenths
all black or dan carter so um there's
always going to be levels to that but
that you might you launch a like i
talked about this before so and i was
into sports cars last year but you might
have a rookie nft as well so in sports
cars your wiki card's always worth the
most because you only get one rookie
card so people will pay you that rookie
card more than any other card
potentially like they could get a little
clip from that as well but
obviously the numbers won't be as wide
but adi might be able to sell a thousand
nfts where this person might be able to
sell 100 yeah it'd be great like for a
fan building exercise as well but in
saying that like the best players the
guys with the most leverage are always
gonna get the most money that's just the
way it is right
exciting times looking forward to seeing
that sort of stuff get into and see who
who stays ahead of the game eh in that
space i think arty arty would be there
he's
yeah i saw a poster he put out like an
nft teaser the other day i'm not sure
um if he's coming out with something
like that soon or i'm not even sure what
the nzw requirements around them are
whether you even if it's possible
because i know they own a lot of the
player rights at the moment and whether
that can change or
what that sort of looks like oh i've
been um talking to clint newton who runs
the rugby league players association
over here and they've done they're doing
a cba pretty soon for nrl and i was like
bro you got to go in and let the players
have their own rights to their own name
so within nrl
say corey's going to go play i can't in
filming on game day like that 24 hours
of game day the nrl and the right swim
as well that's kind of like where the
gold is like we've done we've done a
podcast we've done a vlog a couple years
ago and he ended up opening winning
droppy against west tigers and we filmed
up the whole day bro and it was just i
was the best content i was up all night
editing it and i dropped it at seven
o'clock the next morning and got this
mad reaction off the back of it but like
that's where the gold is bro like i know
i know a lot of people see the 80 minute
performance and stuff like that but
right now
like basketball's my favorite one of my
favorite sports never watched a full
game
what
what's russell westbrook wearing he's in
he's in a skirt at the moment or what's
lebron and i love watching his kids come
up and where these boys eating or stuff
like that bro so i find that a little
cross-correlation between culture and
sports really interesting
so cool and what's the plans for you in
the next sort of five years what what's
uh what's your dreams
um
just be happy bro to be honest like if
that's my personal one like i i love
everything about my life right now love
it from the moment i wake up to the
moment i go to sleep and i just want to
be in this position where i do that i
want yktr sports to be like a serious
player
i don't know where we monetize that or
where we sort of move from that but i
think i'll be able to figure it out and
i want yktr
um my goal is to
provide the most value either
entertainment or education um i just
want to be a part of people's lives i
want to be a part of their watch time on
their phones when they get home i want
to be a part of their wardrobe i want to
be part of things that make me ha them
happy and things that make them think as
well so that's where i'm lined up and
this is where my focus is going and like
i said everything else you can sell a
product or service off the back of that
any way shape or form
so goal be happy
um and two provide value that's kind of
it
right wow how good
as always we've gone to our instagram
for some questions came up with heaps so
many fans just wanted to shout out to
you but i've narrowed it down to a few
uh what percentage of your income do you
allocate to crypto so i know you're big
on crypto so this is good um i'm close
like
it's kind of hard because i've got
four streams of revenue right now so um
i live off one and then pretty much all
the other ones whatever i get that
fluctuates like they're not salaries so
say one week i'll make a thousand
dollars i'll put that whole thousand
dollars in um some weeks i might make
300 on top of
so like i live off my white ktr wage and
then everything else goes into yeah
crypto shares so i'll be going pretty
hard not as hard as tj but um he's
he's he's going good at the moment he's
going really good
he's making enough to check her feed
that in the other major
so he'd be the same like obviously you
get different salaries from
um
nzru and super rugby and stuff like that
so he's probably just living i'm just
guessing he's living offline and
the rest is going in i'd
smart man okay this one i'm not sure
there's must be a back story on this one
but thoughts on the movie the whale
rider
i [ __ ] know who that's from too
charlie gabby
[Laughter]
um no so
funny like when i tore my acl when i
actually toured my acl i um
we ended up going up to neighborhood pub
in kingsland and um keisha castle
hughes was there so we actually had a
little thing for a while
um and yeah so charlie gov had a little
um he knew about that and he's always
just called me well right i want us to
come to training and stuff like that
pretty random pretty random story like
we're hanging out for a little bit and
obviously um a little thing and yeah
just young and
trying to chase that um famous stuff
oh you're a huge fan of the movie then
when i found out when he found out i was
jumping on your podcast
he'd come through my mouth straight away
[Laughter]
and the next one's from jacob lillyman
uh when are you paying your skybell
so what actually happened there um i
remember so like i got let go from the
warriors like pretty abruptly and i was
like oh i'm off to angry yeah so um i
think there was a skype that come
through but i'd taken off back to took
it all by then i was like hey bro i'm
moving home like i've basically run out
of money for the next couple months and
i'm off to the mountain um i have my
girlfriend at the time so
so yeah
just shout on the bill i'll fix you up
now bill if you want
oh that's good stuff okay
ask him what the undefeated pickup line
is
um i want to say it's undefeated but i
just get to giggle out every time so you
kind of just go who are you getting
these from [ __ ] i feel like you're
hanging around me
um so
this used to just work so we should just
go like oh like how did you like you
just be talking normal and then just
abruptly just go like oh how do you do
that and they'll just go like do what
and you just go like look so good like
that's basically it and just kind of
roll off the back works every time works
every time the floyd mayweather will
pick up lines and then they'll laugh
they'll start laughing and then like get
all shy and then like you know what
they're saying like what and if you can
make it your life you can make it do
anything and then the wrist is up to you
so that's that's
that's the lead up and you just gotta um
do the rest work for keisha next minute
your case
[Laughter]
okay tell the listeners about chips
cheese and mayo yeah so it's a little
combination and took it all i feel like
we invented it but um yeah you just get
like chips and cheese and mayo and sort
of wrap it up and it gets all gooey and
um it's nice it's like you like you go
to fish and chip shop and everyone's got
chips cheese and mayo and then like you
have that like raw fish and pretty
random town we've got the most takeaway
spots per capita and
yeah
no just like fish and chips like your
normal stuff oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know you unload like a newspaper yeah
i'm with you yeah by the time it opens
up you just like you pick up a chip and
he's like hanging off and mayo so if you
ever swing through the hood go get some
mate i will that will be first on the
list okay top league player who'd be a
superstar in union
oh tommy turbo obviously um i know you
guys have to do that i know you guys
sort of see that geordie barrett um sort
of
cross collab but um yeah yeah i i think
about like i think about the wallabies
if they had like a cam monster at 12 and
and tommy turbo at the back and addo
ocarina on the wing you can see what
korra betty you can see what corabine is
doing
and like respectfully to corabiti he
wasn't probably an elite winger in in
league
so
um tommy turbo be my first one he could
kick off both feet he'd come from an afl
background he's obviously rapid got
great vision
so yeah he can kick off both feet like
and i mean like place kick as well like
drop it he can hit a drop from like 50
um off both feet so he's a special
talent he's he's the obvious one put him
at the back there um yeah chris latham
vibe socks down put the tool piece
through
mate but how good is turbo going at the
moment in the in the area he's just
absolutely killing it he's going to ride
and obviously went up against melbourne
and they're [ __ ] the crusaders of
they just seem to shut everyone down so
um
and they're a special side as well i
love seeing signs like that
how do you reckon clary would go i know
you probably mentored him through the
through the age grades at the warriors
he was your ball boy wasn't he
he watched a lot of people's games i'd
love to say that but
any further from
the truth but um he'd be good like he's
got a big enough boot you know what i
mean like a lot of us leagues don't have
crazy boots and i know i know um
like the ball is a little bit different
like in union the ball is a bit shorter
and it's not as heavy and you can get
behind it but he's a sweet striker of
the ball um he'd be awesome i think matt
burton
right he's he's one guy that's got a
massive boot for some reason nifty
seemed to kick the ball a lot better
than right footers so
uh if he went clary first five
monster second five matt burton um cena
tommy
slater's bittersweet it's coming it's
coming this way
just be a nice sort of match-up you know
what i mean then you obviously got with
moana and the barrett boys and david
harvey is probably one of my favorite
players at the moment like like
obviously there's a there's such a
technical side to rugby that
a lot of people don't appreciate
um and they'll have to learn that but
nath i think knife would pick it up
pretty quickly he's a smart cookie smart
man how do you reckon roger's gonna go
good where do you see him playing
obviously you know a bit more than me
mate i think he's going to have to start
on the wing but
see where he ends up and how quickly he
can learn it a center or full back would
probably be his best position but i
think he's going to have to start on the
wing to sort of learn the game the best
yeah we'll we'll talk about this the
other day so i like fullbacks when they
can kick the ball as well and um
i know my will jordan had a more run
first and those types of guys and but
they're they're there
like not always have the biggest boot
but knowing winterkick is is just his
skill like a skill set as knowing how to
kick as well so um that'd be hard but
it'd be interesting though because in
football like in league like he's pretty
much got one option when he catches the
ball you just gotta run his shoulders
where if he caught the ball now and
didn't like what he sees potentially
could do a kick but does he have that
kicking game in him i don't know but um
obviously a winger like that you could
see him at corribidi where they can sort
of fight around and you're not really
stuck on that one wing he'd be pretty
interesting yeah uh but ideally like a
13 bro like
my opinion dude because
however he can carry your kicking game
as well like he kicks well yeah um but
then you just you get him a little bit
wider and now roger knows how to play at
the back as well you can sort of do
pretty much how quite went to korea
like out the back there and he can skin
people so um he's got some options but i
think 13 would be nice for me
do you think he makes the all blacks
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah good let's do
hairstyle
and spain there like suddenly took us
time to get there eh
yeah people forget that too and same
with like nani um
he he wasn't an instant um all that he
even took he took like sort of four
years before he really understood the
game same with sort of sunny must have
been like three or four years
where he was playing for what's what's
hard to become about that middle part of
the field like what's the what's the um
i i think the biggest thing the hardest
thing is probably the communication they
have to give the ten you have to really
understand the game like the ten relies
a lot on their 12
and full backs and 13s to give them the
right information the 10's not always
calling those those shots so
if if you've got a 12 who's played
league and not giving you much you're
probably going to struggle as the 10 and
then
yeah the game the whole game sort of
malfunctions from there and you're
looking you know like league is always
looking for contact
just caring try and run over people and
then [ __ ] lose the ball boys kick it
later what hey can i ask you a question
why was conrad smith so good smart real
smart guy like um knew the game really
well was fit
um but he's he's one of those guys that
you would rock up he'd be a little bit
like you you go watch him play a club
club game and you'd be like how the hell
is he one of the greatest all blacks to
play because
he wouldn't stand out in the game of
club rugby but the higher the level he
went he was just always thinking next
job like his mindset was just
yeah he was just switched on all the
time he was fit his work rate was
massive and just his communication and
accuracy was just next level so when he
was in those higher teams like
everything he did was just quality you
know and wasn't making those errors and
things
because like when you look at a 13 i was
like oh you kind of wanted to be big and
strong and bumping off people yeah but i
remember john hart he was um he was like
our director of football at the warriors
and a few of the aussie boys are like oh
like what's it go for like um
what's the go with smith why is he
always picked in that night pretty much
it was richie dan and then him he's like
third in and like basically you know you
said as well so obviously our lack of
knowledge in terms of union doesn't
really like obviously
anonymity like yeah [ __ ] he's just
running over people he deserves to be
there so yeah
interesting it is because i mean he his
well even like his catch pass wasn't
that great couldn't kick the ball he had
like if you look at him from a skill and
like strength he was weak as in the gym
he was slow was he
how is he like the great one of the
greatest centers of all time but he is i
mean
he gives hope to all the white battlers
i remember they've done a room raiders
they'd done the room raiders when they
went to the world cup one time and they
went into his room and he was reading
like
in books like that thick as well so he
must have been clever cookie okay
last question as always what is the best
piece of advice you've ever received and
i know you give out a lot of free advice
and
um as always very good quality so this
is going to be potentially the greatest
of all time no i use my own one bro so
like the big thing my thing is is like
the way the way i measure success is
like the first five seconds in the
morning like are you excited to get up
or you're not
um that's basically it like that's how i
measure success am i excited to get up
or not and people know the difference
between a monday and a saturday like
like when it's a saturday they're
excited because they like they've
compartmentalized their life but for me
i get to wake up every single day and do
exactly what i'm doing and what i want
to oh exactly what i do and sorry
[ __ ] mixing up my words like do we
get to do what i love every single day
and like like i was up at 2 30 this
morning and like a lot of people will
see that i was like what the [ __ ] you
doing up at that time but i'm excited
like i'm excited to get up and and turn
up every day and do something and try
and create something and i'm confident
bro like i'll say stuff then i'll fail
as well so
um that's just me bro are you excited to
get up in the first five seconds or not
that's it
2 30. how come you're up like that is
real early what time do you go to bed
like what's the what's is there a reason
behind getting up so early other than
being really excited
no it's just just what time i wake up
bro um i don't know like it's usually
around 3 30. i've always sort of been an
early riser but i go to bed at like 7 30
straight after shortly
so i'm in bed and i watch like youtube
stuff and then i kind of just like nod
off and then
when i wake up i just wake up and get
going
get so much [ __ ] done bro like no one's
yeah no one's boxing me no one's asking
me for anything there's no invoices
coming out there's no staff problems
it's my favorite time
so how do you get excited for those
first five seconds i mean a lot of
people would think yeah it's cool that
you're you're waking up and you're
excited to get up but a lot of i know a
lot of people like you say aren't and
how do they how do they get excited
about that morning erica
it's you got to be doing what you love
so like the way i talk about my life
right now was like um
you know when you go on holiday bro like
when you go to bali and it's like
you're like oh i got here three days ago
and i've got another four nights like
you know i mean you don't know the
difference between a monday and a
saturday or anything like that that's
kind of how my life is
so um it's easy for me to stay there now
and go like if you hate your job change
your career but um i think it's really
important if you do want to change your
lifestyle or do something that you love
it's important how you spend
what you do after work as well so you've
got to put pressure on yourself
after work and then eventually you can
get to a point where whether that's
online learning or finding mentors or
starting an e-commerce business i don't
know what your [ __ ] thing is you just
got to figure that out and
one of the questions i used to ask
myself is if i got to wake up wake up
and do um what would my dream day look
like
and then i just reverse engineered from
there and for me like like i said before
like i don't really love clothes but
i love like
rocking up and hanging around my mates
and and like being creative in some way
shape or form whether that's marketing
and uh travel was my big one bro like i
said i just want to be able to travel
whenever i wanted and obviously by
selling clothes um i'm light bro i can
go to new york or if i've got a laptop i
can work from there or
i can go to bali that was kind of like
my big thing and then i just reverse
engineered from there i wanted to be
able to travel and create and be on my
own terms and i just reverse engineered
from that here i
so good i knew it would be the best
advice we'd had like oh
and i mean you're doing in a circle now
too so if people listeners are keen to
jump on this go get amongst us it will
change your life you've heard snippets
of ice
yeah you're sponsoring today
we brought you bro
in nelson marput like tasman area yeah
is that nice around there
so nice mate is it so you use the top of
the top of the south island top of the
south island yeah yeah yeah
yeah what's your population around there
um poor what's our population um 70 000
oh so it's quite
big it might be less than that actually
you've challenged me now that you've
challenged me i think it might be a bit
less it's not that big i was looking at
you we're almost the same age bro you're
like four days older than me i know and
same weight same height as well
honestly really appreciate you coming on
the podcast mate like like i said at the
start you've inspired so many people and
it's so cool seeing what you're doing
you're
big inspiration for me love watching
what you're doing love love your podcast
love all all the attributes that you're
bringing to the content game and make so
cool to
get in touch with you and connect with
you and
see looking forward to what you've got
in the future
thanks bro i appreciate that and
obviously um great to just sort of jump
on and chop it up with you and i'm sure
we'll do plenty more of these but um if
you ever need anything but you've got my
inbox anyway so hit me up
you're a lad appreciate it bro
thanks paul see you later